later
kanessa Fran talk to me about your
initial reactions to chilling adventures
obviously that you're someone and
everyone's looked up to with Sabrina how
are you feeling about the new show yeah
I have no real I'm not everyone I think
assumed even like my brother is people
sending me texts saying you know you
okay about this I was like actually some
of the cast members like Ally me Dollard
and they were like you all right you
okay like when it was announced a year
or so ago and I was like no I'm totally
like it's a different story it's a
totally different thing she's got the
same name but that's about it so and we
look kind of similar maybe back then but
that's you know that's really where the
similarities end I mean the shows are so
different I'm glad that the character
you're gonna live on I'm glad that it
has a new sort of you know remake and
and retelling and you know God bless our
spells were more like like sparkles fly
out and Twitter I feel like if it was
very similar it would you would have
something to compare it to but you
really don't
so it's it's totally different and I
think that I've done some Instagram
posts and stuff for them just saying
like you know congratulations go get em
and stuff cuz it's like in a way that's
my character that's family you know um
and this is why everyone loves you you
know that right
before I'm looking for important things
to get like worked up over then whether
or not Sabrina gets renamed Melissa Joan
Hart seems unfazed by Netflix is Sabrina
reboot as she stepped out for the
premiere of Disney's The Nutcracker and
the four realms
[Music]
to be a magical night this is magical if
you could cast a spell on any celebrity
or influential person who would it be
and why I'm not going to politics I want
to but I'm not I hope gosh I you know
what I'd like to spend I spend a little
bit time asteroid temple and I'd love to
while she is passed on I would love to
have one more sit down with her I would
love to have a little bit more time with
her I was young when we met I was like
22 but I wasn't mature enough to handle
the conversation my mother was there as
well and I feel like I was so starstruck
I didn't get my moment with her I was
invited to her home I mean she is my
idol from the time I was little girl
she's the reason I do this and to be
able to be invited into her home I was
just like like soak up all that wisdom
so I could go back and first of all
remember what she said and ask her a few
more questions so that'd be my magical
spell that'd be a great lunch a great
day I mean so much wisdom Twitter it
these days or back then I couldn't
[Music]